the future of this universe rests on
opening a box I'm going to tell you
what's in that box
Gweneth Paltrow insurgent so insurgents
the sequel to divergent they sound so
much alike I almost got tripped up there
and it's in the futures post apocalypse
kind of thing this is one city that's
left and in this world people ultimately
break up into factions there five
factions and everyone does something
either here's a gardeners or the park or
people or the politicians etc etc but
there are some people who don't fit in
any faction so shailene Woodley's a
divergent she's one of the ones who
doesn't fit in and now she's trying to
take on the man she's fighting she
president snow played by Kate Winslet so
now they're trying to get an army
together to get their full on assault
their civil war that they want to break
out and other things in the movie it's
way too convoluted because this movie is
way too convoluted I think this movie
knew really where it was going that's a
problem lately I've seen it more and
more it's like movies try to be clever
in being clever they think having all of
these plot points in this movie that
don't really link to each other that's
really clever
no it makes movie fuel crowded and
convoluted and confusing not like clever
confusing words like those I really
think about it I'll get it no there's
not like deeper meaning [ __ ] it's just
poorly written plot points but shouting
out some positive shailene Woodley's
good in the movie cuz shailene Woodley's
a good actress
she really is there are some scenes for
you like oh you're really bringing it
you got the emotion props to you and
she's pretty much the one who's bringing
it I feel like everyone else in this
movie didn't want to be here it's like
they're all like we're on to bigger and
better things now since we did the first
movie you know that feeling you get when
you roll out of bed you're like I don't
want to go to work today or in the case
of the target audience of this movie I
don't want to go to school today we've
all felt it we all know it it's like all
the supporting cast in this movie they
all felt that every day they were
filming this movie they showed and so L
gort's like I'm doing better things now
is in The Fault in Our Stars you know
how many teenage girls want this they
want to hit this I don't want to be here
today miles teller like dude I acted
with JK Simmons and I did a great job in
that movie I don't want to be here today
Kate Winslet's like I will just stand
there stoic Lee and just say a couple of
menacing things because I don't want to
be here either does everyone in this
movies expendable income there are a
couple times was like oh my god
I should that person I can't believe
they did that that person may or may not
have died but did I care no because I
can't even recall whether or not that
person's important that's how
forgettable the characters are sadly
there were a couple good action
sequences sure the movie starts out
you're like oh it's gonna be boring oh
shoot there's an action sequence pretty
early on in the movie and then there are
action sequences later on you know when
you know the test is going down oh
really it's the tests that interest you
because I like it when people have to
take tests the test could have had no
action sequences whatsoever and I would
have been entertained because like whose
test that's cool everything else leading
up to that was just like these rabbit
trail plot points were you like focus up
dude see divergent actually pulled me
into its world I was surprised how much
I actually liked this world for people
faction off into their own things and
she had to ultimately audition to be the
parkour people and I like that because
she's kind of the underdog but this next
movie insurgent didn't step it up at all
yeah it seemed to be a bigger world but
it wasn't better ultimately an insurgent
shailene woodley is the glue that's
holding this movie together
none of the supporting cast looked like
they wanted to be in this movie the
first half of this movies just messy
plot going everywhere the second half of
the movie focuses up and is more
enjoyable for sure but by then it's just
too late cuz insurgent would probably be
a good time if you're drunk yeah now is
the boring holy [ __ ] does a cast even
want to be here they look bored they
looks bored it's really funny doctor as
I went into a bookstore surprisingly
they still exist young adult novels were
an actual section it was a whole thing
shelves I mean we're talking shelves
upon shelves of books that I'd never
heard of that will inevitably be
translated into movies they're not gonna
stop they're just gonna keep coming
right so insurgent have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more